all right saturn hey
saturn uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally uh oklahoma
oklahoma yeah and tell me about your
childhood growing up you had mom and dad
uh no i never had a mom or dad i was
orphan i stayed with my grandparents um
until my grandpa or grandma died at when
i was like 13 my grandpa went crazy
so i stayed with my uncle in missouri
and he abandoned me after a month and i
went toward the state of missouri and
went to group homes and
lockdowns and stuff and uh until i was
18.
so then i went back to my grandpa
to check up on him after they kicked me
out he's still all crazy and
got a great hound and decided to go to
atlanta opportunity here
california at what age did you come out
i was like
19 i think yeah 19 around 19.
yeah and then um
yeah that was my childhood i guess short
and sweet version of it any
traumatic events or anything terrible um
just the emotional damage from that
yeah that's enough and then some of the
group homes and
stuff i had some issues but there's some
horror stories from that yeah yeah
from that program what uh
what have you done since you came to l.a
oh my god i've done a lot
um well i was on the streets i was
homeless when i first got out here
i literally never seen a beach or palm
tree in my life being in the midwest you
know
and i wanted to experience that so when
i got off the greyhound
i was asked people where's the beach at
where's the beach how do i get to the
beach and like
people just told me what buses get on
and i went straight to santa monica
jumped in the water it was february and
it was hot out but the water was
freezing it freaked me out but uh
that was funny um
yeah and i i met these homeless guys
it's like hey how does this work out
here like where do i get food
what do i do and we hung out got drunk
underneath the pier and uh made some
friends and
yeah um
started learning about how to do things
on the streets and how to get
supplies and stuff without money and
yeah and then i did that for about
a few years and got in trouble
and decided uh i love my freedom too
much and i can't get
my freedom taken away from me again so i
need to straighten my [ __ ] up
so i worked on venice beach
at a poster store and then worked at
uh pokey restaurant and ended up working
there for like five years and became the
manager there
and i worked at whole foods i've worked
a lot of places i can't
name them all i'll be here all day but
yeah i've got a good
rap sheet of work how old do you know
i'm 33
33 yeah and drugs have been a part of
your life oh yeah yeah i did tons of
drugs
especially on the streets right what
were your favorites
huh what were your favorites ketamine
acid i like all psychedelics mushrooms
um yeah ketamine tell me about ketamine
ketamine uh it's great um
it's great because like it's uh
not only can you party with it you can
use it to benefit yourself like
depression
and stuff like that it's like you're
feeling good you get a
good little head rush and then ketamine
is actually an animal tranquilizer right
yeah yeah yeah yeah you can get
different grades of it too like there's
like human grades like rhinogram or like
different strengths you know and um
a lot of it going around in la right now
it's like it's like human grades like
not too powerful but and like your
tolerance it grows with ketamine too
it's like
if you do it for a couple days like
you're gonna have to do more
like it's like your tongue screw is
really quick like it is addictive
yeah it can be addictive yeah it doesn't
it depends on a person like when i was
younger on the streets like when i did
drugs like
i could take months off drugs and then
get back on it like i didn't have no
problem with addiction
at that time like i didn't crave
anything but as i got older i noticed i
crave drugs more and it's like
really annoying and ketamine is uh
something you snort or use a pill you
can snort it you can uh muscle it
um you can um i believe they do have
pills you can
they have sprays too um it's mostly like
a party drug right yeah yeah yeah
yeah but it's been used throughout for a
long time through other things too like
um
i've read something about um
what um spiritual what's that called
occults and stuff using it because it
helps separate the soul from the body
and they would use that for different
rituals and stuff but uh
what so what's the effect from doing
ketamine oh well you kind of just like
it's a dissociative kind of psychedelic
and
you just kind of like fall out and go
into another universe or you
everything around you just like melts
away and you
go into other dimensions it feels like
or something how does it compare to
lsd or mushrooms lsd is like
you never really know for sure what
you're going to get with it
like like last couple times into the llc
it's like
they weren't great trips they were kind
of bad trips and i thought it was gonna
be great but
i was wrong and um
ketamine is always great so it's always
the same thing basically
so it lasts for how long um
traditionally like 15 to 30 minutes
right yeah it seems to be getting better
nowadays feel like a lot of the
ketamines are lasting a little bit
longer
i don't know why so it doesn't really
you don't really find it on the streets
of skid row but you'll find it at the
clubs
you find night clubs you can you can
find it everywhere you actually they
have pharma
there's they're starting to do
pharmacies now i believe like
where you can go to a clinic and get
ketamine uh muscled into you and like
they it's good for uh ptsd
and uh depression so
it's an antidepressant and what so what
do you use any
other drugs like crystal meth or any
other no no i played around with it
though
yeah right now and now that you're
trying to get your your life straight
would it would it oh yeah yeah
what have you learned from your years of
drug use um
i've learned that
we we all have tendencies to get
addicted to things pretty easily
especially if you have a lot of traumas
and
stuff you've been through and like
pharmacies from uh pharmaceutical stuff
is
it's like legal drug dealing it's legal
drugs
and the legal drugs kind of
you can do the same thing like you can
legally sell
well i'm trying to say here um
basically i'm saying like if you use
illegal drugs and
have self-discipline and you do use them
as a tool
instead of partying like it could help
some people
but some drugs some people shouldn't be
taking we're all different we're all
different fingerprints
like so i've learned
that if you do too much of anything it's
really bad for you and like
and something that can be recreational
can turn into something that's yeah
addictive
exactly and then you can [ __ ] your life
up and then you have to get help and
then
you're behind and you see people that
are that have problems with the things
like ketamine oh yeah yeah
yeah definitely actually one of my best
friends was like stuck on
and he's about to have a kid and he had
to get off of it before he had a kid and
he was struggling really hard
him and his wife and like they had to
get help they couldn't do it on their
own
so yeah it can be heavily addictive and
what does the club seem like with with
what are the other drugs that people oh
molly uh
molly's great i love molly but um
ecstasy cocaine um
of course academy mushrooms acid
stuff like that
yeah and uh you got those you got some
weird clubs though too you got
you got you got different kinds of clubs
you got some clubs that's like or
underground warehouses or something like
that that
you got a bunch of meth heads there it's
like then you got the ones that are
psychedelic hippie flipping and [ __ ] and
then
you got to like you just got different
drugs in different scenes you know
what do you think the why why are drugs
so popular now
because they're great they feel great
and people but
you touched that earlier and you're in
your like childhood you went through a
lot of
traumatic stuff yeah yeah do you think
that's the core of it all
i mean it it definitely where people
just bought it it's a part of it yeah
it's definitely a part of it
um i'm learning right now how to do
shadow work and how do you dig into my
past
and like not distract myself and face my
inner darkness
and um that's what i'm working on right
now so like
drugs are a great distraction sore
females or or whatever you're into
um and i i like distracting myself a lot
and i'm trying to figure out why
so and i'm sure it has something to do
with my childhood yeah i think once we
get bored and kind of don't have
anything to focus on i think
drugs became like becoming an easy oh
yeah very easy
thing to go to yeah definitely yeah
you're bored you're sitting around with
some friends and it's funny sometimes
when i'm bored i have
tons of things i want to do or should do
but
i choose to do the drugs or [ __ ] go
hang out with the chick or something
yeah i mean la's a big city like yeah
but you go to
some of these more rural areas where you
think like oh they wouldn't have drugs
there it's worse there
yeah because there's nothing to do yeah
everyone's just sitting around bored and
it's almost like everybody is doing the
drugs yeah yeah it's
it seems that way actually it's like
some i remember when i started doing
some drugs like
i was shocked that some of my homies was
like wait you've been doing this this
whole time what
like i didn't even know they were doing
direct they've all been good the whole
time though
they seem like sober clean people and
say wow
and what have you learned in your in
your life that
stuck with you what's the most important
thing you've learned oh god
i've learned a lot it's hard to pinpoint
it's like finding a needle in haystack
i've learned a lot
um that's a good answer there's a lot
there's a lot of things to learn yeah
there is if you're paying attention
yeah um
i've learned that self-discipline is
very important and it's really hard
but uh i don't know that's i guess the
first thing that pops in my head right
now it's a rare one too
yeah all right saturn thank you so much
for sharing your story yeah no problem
man
you